Dad, now, what we're going to do is we're going to go through this thing, and there'll be stopping and starting. Hello?
爸爸，现在我们要做的是，我们将通读这个东西，中间会有停顿和开始。喂？
Yeah, I'm here.
嗯，我在。
OK, hi.
好的，嗨。
Hi.
嗨。
There'll be stopping and starting. And basically, if you feel like saying anything you want over the course of this, it'll be better if you just jump in and say it. OK?
会有停顿和开始。基本上，如果你想在过程中说点什么，直接插话说是最好的。好吗？
OK.
好的。
For Father's Day this year, it seemed fun to rerun this episode from the earliest days of our radio show. This is an episode that I co-hosted with my dad. And this was made so long ago that my father in this recording, he's the same age that I am right now, in 2023, as I'm saying these words to you.
今年的父亲节，重播我们广播节目早期的一集似乎很有趣。这一集是我和我父亲共同主持的。这期节目制作得非常久远，以至于录音里的父亲，和我现在——2023年对着你们说话时的我，是同样的年纪。
OK, so Dad, so you have the script.
好的，爸爸，你拿到稿子了吧。
I have the script.
我有稿子。
And have you been practicing?
你练习过了吗？
Like crazy.
练疯了。
Can I hear just a little sample of you reading something?
我能听听你读的一小段样本吗？
Sure. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, the Father's Day edition.
当然。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》父亲节特辑。
Dad, you are such a pro.
爸爸，你真是个专业人士。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
I haven't done this in 40 years. It brings back all kinds of memories.
我已经40年没干这行了。这勾起了各种回忆。
Now, you better explain to our radio listeners in what context you actually sat in front of a radio microphone, Dad.
现在，你最好跟我们的电台听众解释一下，你当年是在什么背景下坐在电台麦克风前的，爸爸。
Well, it was around 1955 or 1956 when I graduated from Maryland. And instead of getting an honest job, I went to work in radio.
那是1955年或1956年左右，我从马里兰大学毕业的时候。与其找份正经工作，我选择了去电台工作。
So here's a tape of what you sounded like back in 1956 on the radio.
这是一段你1956年在电台工作的录音。
Oh, please don't play that tape.
哦，求求你，别放那段录音。
This is three years before I was born. And you're just a kid in this recording. You are 23 years old.
这是在我出生前三年。录音里的你还是个孩子。你当时才23岁。
Do personal problems and worries have you down? Are you disturbed by business problems, marriage problems, or emotional problems? See Mrs. K, reader and advisor. Mrs. K, formerly of Europe, gives you a reading and answers all your questions for just $1, and you'll feel much better.
个人问题和烦恼让你沮丧吗？你被商业问题、婚姻问题或情感问题困扰吗？去见K夫人，阅读者兼顾问。K夫人原籍欧洲，只需1美元就能为你解读并回答你所有的问题，你会感觉好多了。
How could somebody, Dad, how could somebody who's charging $1 for a reading even afford to buy a radio ad?
爸爸，怎么可能有人只收1美元的咨询费还能买得起电台广告呢？
Well, look, she's been to Europe. She got her education there. So they must have taught her something over there.
嘿，听着，她去过欧洲。她在那里接受过教育。所以他们一定教过她一些东西。
[LAUGHING] So, now, at some point, you gave up your burgeoning career in radio really before it took off the ground, and that was because?
[笑声] 那么，在某个时间点，你放弃了你那还没起步就夭折的电台生涯，那是为了什么？
It was nothing important. It was something called making a living.
没什么重要的。就是为了谋生。
Right, and so now you're a certified public accountant living in Baltimore.
好吧，所以现在你是一位住在巴尔的摩的注册会计师。
Right.
是的。
Well, let me say this. Let me give a little explanation that we try to give each show for new listeners. Each week in our program, we document stories of life in these United States, using all the tools of radio storytelling-- documentaries, monologues, found tapes, anything we can think of. And today, for Father's Day my co-host will be my own father, Barry Glass, certified public accountant.
好吧，让我说几句。我要给新听众做一点简单的说明。每周我们的节目都会记录这些美国大地上生活的故事，使用广播叙事的所有工具——纪录片、独白、现成的录音，任何我们能想到的。今天，为了父亲节，我的联合主持人将是我的父亲，巴里·格拉斯，注册会计师。
And it's a real kick to do this.
做这件事真是种享受。
I know. This is our little Father's Day adventure together.
我知道。这是我们父子俩小小的父亲节冒险。
You could have bought me a tie.
你本可以给我买条领带的。
Dad, why don't you read the billboard?
爸爸，你为什么不读一下节目预告呢？
Our program today will have four acts. Act One, Sandra Tsing Loh finds out that the world sees her father very differently from the way she sees him.
我们今天的节目将有四幕。第一幕，桑德拉·清·罗发现世界看待她父亲的方式与她眼中的截然不同。
Act 2, "And If That Diamond Ring Don't Shine," Ian Brown talks about everyday moments that test any father.
第二幕，“如果那枚钻戒不闪亮”，伊恩·布朗讲述了考验每一位父亲的日常时刻。
Act 3, "The Moment Dad Left."
第三幕，“父亲离开的那一刻”。
Act 4, "Reconciling With Dad."
第四幕，“与父亲和解”。
A story from playwright Beau O'Reilly.
剧作家博·奥莱利的一个故事。
So, Dad, take us into Act 1, will you, please?
那么，爸爸，带我们进入第一幕吧，好吗？
Act 1, "How the World Sees Your Father."
第一幕，“世界如何看待你的父亲”。
So, Dad, our first story today is from Los Angeles. It's from Sandra Tsing Loh, as you said at the beginning of the show in the billboard. When she was growing up, her father was not a fun dad. He himself had been orphaned in Shanghai when he was 12. He was raised in poverty, and because of that, he was just this-- penny pincher doesn't even capture it. He was miserly.
好的，爸爸，我们今天第一个故事来自洛杉矶。正如你在开头预告中所说，来自桑德拉·清·罗。她成长过程中，她的父亲不是个有趣的爸爸。他自己12岁时在上海成了孤儿。他在贫困中长大，正因为如此，他是个——守财奴都无法形容他。他非常吝啬。
They didn't celebrate Christmas. He never took his children to Disneyland, even though it was less than an hour away from their home. There were no real vacations. Sandra tells the story once she bought a book of Charlie Brown comics for $1 at a book fair, and her father threw it across the room, furious at how she had wasted money. He was really strict. But as Sandra found out recently, not everyone in the world sees her father the way she does.
他们不过圣诞节。他从不带孩子们去迪士尼乐园，尽管离家不到一小时车程。没有什么真正的假期。桑德拉讲过一个故事，有一次她在书展上花1美元买了一本查理·布朗漫画书，她父亲竟然气得把它扔到房间另一头，愤怒于她浪费了钱。他真的很严格。但正如桑德拉最近发现的那样，并不是世界上所有人都像她那样看待她的父亲。
There's a kind of news that you're never prepared for, and here, last week, was mine. A friend told me that, incredibly, a local grunge band had composed a rock anthem about my dad and was performing it to great response in Malibu area clubs.
有一种新闻是你永远无法准备好的，这就是上周发生在我身上的事。一位朋友告诉我，令人难以置信的是，当地一支垃圾摇滚乐队创作了一首关于我爸爸的摇滚赞歌，并且在马里布地区的俱乐部表演时反响热烈。
The group in question was called Boy Hits Car, and the song, a wailing rock cri de coeur powered by Pearl Jam-like riffs, was, in fact called "Mr. Loh." The actual cover of the Boy Hits Car demo tape was a grainily xeroxed photo of a tiny, wizened 76-year-old Chinese man, grinning on a Malibu beach in tattered swim trunks, which was, indeed, my father.
这支乐队叫Boy Hits Car，这首歌是一首充满痛苦的摇滚呐喊，伴随着类似珍珠果酱乐队的重复段，歌名实际上就叫“罗先生”。Boy Hits Car试听磁带的封面，是一个颗粒粗糙的复印照片，上面是一个瘦小、干瘪、76岁的中国老人，在马里布海滩上咧着嘴笑，穿着破烂的泳裤，那确实是我父亲。
I have to admit, however, that the Mr. Loh in the song was not one I was familiar with. As seen through the eyes of lifeguard/singer Craig Rondell, Mr. Loh is a mystical, dreamy figure who swims naked among the dolphins. In the duality that characterizes certain types of rock poetry-- I'm reminded of The Doors-- the natural dance Mr. Loh does on the beach brings the listener comfort while, at the same time, poses a profound spiritual challenge.
然而，我必须承认，歌里的那位罗先生是我不熟悉的。在救生员/歌手克雷格·隆德尔眼中，罗先生是一个神秘、梦幻的人物，他会在海豚中裸泳。在某种摇滚诗歌特有的二元对立中——我想起了大门乐队——罗先生在海滩上做的自然舞蹈既给听众带来了安慰，同时也提出了深刻的精神挑战。
["MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR]
[Boy Hits Car演唱的“罗先生”]
(SINGING) Mr. Loh's not afraid to be naked, but some men fall from grace. They're not secure with themselves. He doesn't measure people by things we consider important. Can't seem to comprehend today, so he swims away.
（歌唱）罗先生不怕赤身裸体，但有些男人却堕落了。他们对自己不够自信。他不以我们认为重要的事物来衡量人。似乎无法理解当今世界，所以他游向远方。
My first instinct was that this had to be a sick Freudian joke one of my siblings was playing on me, as in, what is the most wildly unlikely, most fraught with amazing ironies, most wacky '60s Peter Sellers film thing you can imagine could happen to our family? But no, my father was these Malibu surfers' Eggman. He was their walrus. I decided to meet them. Craig Rondell, bass player Scott Menville, and guitarist Louis Lenard were all too happy to come into a studio and explain how their song came to be.
我的第一直觉是，这肯定是我的某个兄弟姐妹跟我开的一个病态的弗洛伊德式的玩笑，比如，你能想象到的最狂野、最不可能、充满惊人讽刺、最搞怪的60年代彼得·塞勒斯电影情节，怎么会发生在我们家身上？但不是，我父亲就是这些马里布冲浪者的“蛋人”。他是他们的“海象”。我决定见见他们。克雷格·隆德尔、贝斯手斯科特·门维尔和吉他手路易斯·莱纳德非常乐意来到演播室，解释他们的歌是怎么创作出来的。
It was one day at the beach, and there was about five of us just sitting in the sand, just talking. Mr. Loh came casually walking up, and he was standing there for just maybe three seconds without saying anything. And we were kind of like, OK. And then he said, you're all victims of modern technology.
有一天在海滩上，我们大约五个人坐在沙滩上聊天。罗先生随随便便走过来，他在那儿站了大概三秒钟，什么也没说。我们当时想，好吧。然后他说，你们都是现代技术的牺牲品。
I started thinking. I was like, wow, that's deep. And then he just started to talk to us. He would sing, throughout the conversation, he would start singing. And so that's where the song, the premise kind of came from.
我开始思考。我想，哇，这很有深度。然后他就开始跟我们聊天。在交谈过程中，他会唱歌，他会开始唱歌。所以这首歌的前提就是这么来的。
["MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR]
[Boy Hits Car演唱的“罗先生”]
(SINGING) Mr. Loh, will you speak to me? You're the only one I understand. Mr. Loh, will you speak to me? You're the only one who makes sense.
（歌唱）罗先生，你能跟我说说话吗？你是唯一我能理解的人。罗先生，你能跟我说说话吗？你是唯一一个讲道理的人。
Do you remember when you first saw my father? Go ahead, Scott.
你还记得第一次见到我父亲是什么时候吗？你说吧，斯科特。
Oh, I remember. These guys probably have earlier memories, but it was in 1978 after the big fire came. Our house burned down, and we moved to Malibu West. And I remember seeing Mr. Loh stretching naked and then taking a shower outside naked and--
哦，我记得。这些家伙可能记得更早，但那是在1978年大火之后。我们的房子烧毁了，我们搬到了马里布西区。我记得看到罗先生赤身裸体地做伸展运动，然后在外面试着裸体淋浴，而且——
At the beach?
在海滩上？
At the beach. And I thought it was kind of like funny, but like not in a bad way. I thought it was interesting. That was my first memory.
在海滩上。我当时觉得这挺有趣的，但不是那种坏的意义上的有趣。我觉得这很有意思。那是我的第一段记忆。
OK.
好的。
I, too, had similar memories. I mean, I've been at that beach at Malibu since I was in diapers. And five, six, seven, eight years old. I was down there, and I'd notice him doing somersaults in the sand or doing headstands against the wall, naked as well.
我也差不多。我是说，我从还在穿尿布时就去马里布海滩了。五岁、六岁、七岁、八岁。我就在那里，我会注意到他在沙滩上翻筋斗，或者光着身子靠着墙倒立。
So what did you think--
那你觉得——
Talking to these guys, it suddenly occurred to me who my dad really is. You know how every neighborhood has its eccentric-- the cat lady, the parrot man, the guy with the umbrella hat and recycling cart who yells? Well, in my Southern Californian hometown, Malibu West, my dad is that person. It's an unsettling thing to realize about one of your own parents.
和这些家伙交谈时，我突然意识到我爸爸到底是谁。你知道每个街区都有那种怪人——养猫的女士、玩鹦鹉的人、戴着雨伞帽推着回收车大喊大叫的人？好吧，在我的南加州家乡马里布西区，我爸爸就是那个人。意识到自己父母之一是这样的人，感觉真不安。
And behind Mr. Loh's back, he was known as the Naked Handstand Man.
在罗先生背后，他被称为“裸体倒立男”。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For years, I didn't even know his name. I just thought he was the Naked Handstand Man.
多年来，我甚至不知道他的名字。我只以为他是“裸体倒立男”。
You're going to have to do the song.
你得唱那首歌。
The song? What do you mean, the song?
那首歌？你是说哪首歌？
Scott wrote another-- I'm going to put him on the spot.
斯科特还写了另一首——我要让他当众表演一下。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
Wait, there's a Naked Handstand song?
等等，还有一首关于“裸体倒立”的歌？
Yes, of course there's a Naked Handstand Man song. Unbelievably, the "Mr. Loh" song they'd recorded was only the latest in a decade-long aesthetic exploration of my father on the part of Boy Hits Car bassist Scott Menville.
是的，当然有“裸体倒立男”之歌。令人难以置信的是，他们录制的“罗先生”只是Boy Hits Car贝斯手斯科特·门维尔长达十年对我父亲进行审美探索的最新成果。
OK, it was like (SINGING) I was walking down the beach one day. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. I happened to turn and look his way. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. This is the man that we all know. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. And his name is Mr. Loh. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. He stood right there with his head in the sand. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. He's the Naked Handstand Man. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. Mr. Loh, Mr. Loh.
好吧，大概是这样的（歌唱）有一天我在海滩上散步，登登登登登登，碰巧转过头看了他一眼，登登登登登登，这就是我们都知道的那个人，登登登登登，他的名字叫罗先生，登登登登登，他站在那里，头扎进沙子里，登登登登登，他就是裸体倒立男，登登登登登，罗先生，罗先生。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Something like that. We were like 12.
差不多就是这样。我们当时大概12岁。
I invited my father to join me and the band in the studio. He doesn't really see all the fuss about his nakedness.
我邀请了我的父亲和我以及乐队一起进录音室。他并不觉得他的裸体有什么大不了的。
For example, at Stanford University, which I went there, too, in the men's swimming pool, everybody was naked because that's the most hygienic, most clean thing to do, you see.
例如，在斯坦福大学，我也去过那里，在男子游泳池里，每个人都是赤身裸体的，因为那是最高效、最干净的做法，你明白吧。
But if some young people want to see his nakedness as a symbol of something more important, well, my father is happy to be of service.
但如果一些年轻人想把他的裸体看作某种更重要事物的象征，好吧，我父亲很乐意效劳。
The way I discovered this tape was this. One day, maybe a couple of months ago, I hitchhiked. And a couple of young men picked me up. They say, Mr. Loh, we hear that tape about you. Oh, I say, those rascals. They did tape. They didn't tell me. And it's very nice. I feel very happy, very honored. Probably if they don't write any song about me, probably nobody will ever write about me. So this is my life chance.
我发现这盘磁带的过程是这样的。有一天，也许是几个月前，我搭便车。两个年轻人载了我。他们说，罗先生，我们听了那首关于你的歌。哦，我说，这些淘气的家伙。他们居然录了歌。他们没告诉我。这非常好。我觉得很高兴，很荣幸。如果他们不写歌，可能没人会写我。所以这是我人生中的机会。
Of course, that's not true because I've made my career writing about you.
当然，这不是真的，因为我的职业生涯就是写你。
Yeah, but not song, you see. You see, you are on the writing. So I appreciate that, too. But I like something different. That's very precious for me, see.
是的，但不是歌，你懂吧。你看，你是在写文章。所以我也很感激。但我喜欢不同的东西。这对我很珍贵，你看。
Of course, with all due respect to the members of Boy Hits Car, in my opinion, my father is the least likely candidate to become a symbol of individual freedom of spiritual introspection of the healing powers of nature. After all, this is a man who believed all three of his children should get PhDs in engineering, or else they would starve in the street. Then, again, all these things may be a matter of personal interpretation.
当然，在尊重Boy Hits Car成员的同时，在我看来，我父亲是那种最不可能成为个人自由、精神内省或自然疗愈力量象征的人。毕竟，这是一个认为他的三个孩子都应该拿到工程学博士学位，否则就会饿死在街头的人。话又说回来，这一切可能都是个人解读的问题。
So you see my father's nakedness as kind of a rebellion of some sort, or?
所以你觉得我父亲的裸体是一种反叛，还是？
No. Not actually. I just--
不，其实不是。我只是——
Just natural.
只是自然而已。
Yeah, he's just being natural.
是的，他只是顺应自然。
I feel that he has the ability to go beyond the general stereotype that America holds in that regard and is free.
我觉得他有能力超越美国对这方面的普遍刻板印象，而且他是自由的。
Contact with nature, now, that's very important. Now, in the society, you are so busy, busy, busy, busy, busy. Not much time to talk to yourself or talk to the nature.
接触大自然，这非常重要。现在在社会上，你们太忙、忙、忙、忙、忙了。没有多少时间跟自己对话或跟大自然对话。
Nature, but did you encourage-- I'm just trying to remember as kids, if you encouraged us to do that.
大自然，但你是否鼓励——我只是在试图回忆小时候，你是否鼓励我们那样做。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
OK, when?
好的，什么时候？
Well, we did many things. We always go along the Zuma Beach to the garbage can to collect those aluminum cans. And we'd compete with the [INAUDIBLE] family. We have to go one step ahead.
嗯，我们做了很多事。我们总是沿着祖马海滩去垃圾桶收集那些铝罐。我们还会和[听不清]一家比赛。我们必须领先一步。
Not to put too fine a point on it, but a competition to collect cans for spare change is not the sort of communing with nature, say, Walt Whitman and Ralph Waldo Emerson extolled, which brings me to another point.
说得不太客气点，为了零钱去收集铝罐的竞争，并不是沃尔特·惠特曼和拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生所推崇的那种与自然共融，这引出了我的另一点看法。
I have to say, there is something sort of poignant about sitting in a room full of young people who are hanging onto my father's every word. He's like an odd little guru, they his apostles. God knows he never got that from my sister or brother or me. At one point, for reasons too complicated to explain here, my father sang the boys in the band a Chinese folk song that he had translated into French.
我必须说，坐在满屋子热切聆听我父亲每一句话的年轻人中间，有一种凄凉感。他就像个古怪的小导师，他们是他的门徒。上帝知道我姐姐、哥哥或我从来没得到过那种待遇。有一次，由于原因过于复杂无法在这里解释，我父亲给乐队的男孩们唱了一首他翻译成法语的中国民歌。
[SINGING IN FRENCH]
[用法语歌唱]
Yeah!
太棒了！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Were you crying?
你当时哭了吗？
I must say that the tears were coming.
我必须说泪水涌出来了。
Why? Why? Why?
为什么？为什么？为什么？
That was just beautiful. That was just an unhindered true expression of something that I just felt that was totally genuine. It just gave me the chills.
那实在太美了。那是一种毫无保留的真实表达，我感觉那是完全真诚的。这让我起鸡皮疙瘩。
Should I sing another one?
我应该再唱一首吗？
Why not? Sing another one. If this makes my father happy, well, then, I guess I'll try to be happy for him.
为什么不呢？再唱一首。如果这能让我父亲快乐，那么，我想我会试着为他感到高兴。
["MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR]
[Boy Hits Car演唱的“罗先生”]
(SINGING) Mr. Loh, he finds the water and seems to wash this place off as the dolphins jump and play. He speaks to us in the sand. Do you know the meaning of life, or are you just a simple man? And then he swims away.
（歌唱）罗先生，他找到水，似乎洗去了这个地方，海豚跳跃嬉戏。他在沙滩上对我们说话。你知道生命的意义，还是你只是个简单的人？然后他游向远方。
Dad, do you have the script for the back notes?
爸爸，你有背景介绍的脚本吗？
Yeah, I have it.
嗯，我有。
OK, why don't you give the back notes?
好的，为什么你不读一下背景介绍呢？
Sandra Tsing Loh is a writer, performer, composer, and columnist for Buzz Magazine.
桑德拉·清·罗是作家、表演者、作曲家和《Buzz》杂志专栏作家。
This is Ira in 2023, today's show's rerun. I am jumping in to say that Sandra actually has a new comedy called Mad Women of the West that's running at the Odyssey Theater in Los Angeles right now. Her dad, Mr. Loh, died a few years ago at the age of 96. And the band did a live performance of this song at his wake.
我是艾拉，2023年。今天的节目是重播。我插进来告诉大家，桑德拉其实有一部名为《西部疯狂女性》的新喜剧，目前正在洛杉矶奥德赛剧院上演。她的爸爸，罗先生，几年前去世了，享年96岁。乐队在他的葬礼上现场表演了这首歌。
["MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR]
[Boy Hits Car演唱的“罗先生”]
(SINGING) Mr. Loh's not afraid to be naked.
（歌唱）罗先生不怕赤身裸体。
Hey, Dad, one of the things that you often complained to me about, about stories that you hear on Public Radio is that they're too long. How are we doing so far?
嘿，爸爸，你经常跟我抱怨的一个关于公共广播节目的问题是，它们太长了。到目前为止我们表现如何？
How long was that story, in total?
那个故事总共多长？
The total story is about 11 minutes.
整个故事大约11分钟。
That's a pretty long piece.
那是一个相当长的片段。
Too long, do you think?
你觉得太长了吗？
Yeah, I think it's too long.
是的，我觉得太长了。
Did your interest flag?
你的兴趣减退了吗？
No, my interest didn't slow down. However, if I were listening to the show at home with other distractions around, it might lag off a little bit, I think.
没有，我的兴趣没有减退。但是，如果我在家听这个节目，周围有其他干扰，可能会稍微有点分心，我想。
(SINGING) Mr. Loh, will you sing to me? You're the only one who makes sense.
（歌唱）罗先生，你能为我唱歌吗？你是唯一一个讲道理的人。
Dad, it's time to open up Act 2.
爸爸，是时候开始第二幕了。
Act 2, "Father's Music."
第二幕，“父亲的音乐”。
Now, Dad, for this act, I asked you to bring in an example of the kinds of music that you, my father, used to play around the house when I was a kid, because you had music going whenever you were home on weekends and--
那么，爸爸，对于这一幕，我请你带来一些当你还是我父亲时，你在家里常放的音乐，因为你周末在家时总会放音乐——
Absolutely.
当然。
OK, so what did you bring in?
好的，你带来了什么？
Well, I brought three Frank Sinatra CDs.
嗯，我带来了三张弗兰克·辛纳屈的CD。
Right on. Can you just choose a song and let's pop that on?
太棒了。你能选一首歌放一下吗？
Sure.
当然。
What have you got?
你有什么？
Probably my favorite Frank Sinatra song, "Lady is a Tramp."
大概是我最喜欢的弗兰克·辛纳屈的歌，“Lady is a Tramp”。
Now, why is this your favorite?
那你为什么最喜欢这一首？
I don't know. I just like the rhythm, like Frank Sinatra's phrasing.
我不知道。我就是喜欢它的节奏，喜欢弗兰克·辛纳屈的咬字。
["LADY IS A TRAMP" BY FRANK SINATRA"]
[弗兰克·辛纳屈演唱的“Lady is a Tramp”]
(SINGING) She gets too hungry for dinner at 8:00. She likes the theater and never comes late.
（歌唱）她8点吃晚饭太饿了。她喜欢剧院，从不迟到。
I remember the 60th birthday party.
我记得你的60岁生日派对。
Your 60th birthday party, of course.
你的60岁生日派对，当然。
Right, where we had the Frank Sinatra impersonator.
对了，我们当时请了弗兰克·辛纳屈模仿者。
Sure.
当然。
Well, this is-- he sang this there. Did a pretty good job, too.
嗯，这就是——他在那里唱了这首歌。唱得还不错。
(SINGING) Doesn't like crap games with barons or earls. Won't go to Harlem in ermine and pearls.
（歌唱）不喜欢和男爵或伯爵玩纸牌游戏。不会穿着貂皮和珍珠去哈莱姆区。
What do you think? Pretty good song?
你觉得呢？不错的歌吧？
It's a great song. And this next story that we're going to do is about a fatherly duty that is linked to a song, but not a good song.
这首歌很棒。接下来的故事是关于一个与歌曲相关的父爱责任，但不是好歌。
So it's not "Lady is a Tramp" or anything like that.
所以不是“Lady is a Tramp”之类的。
Oh, definitely not. This song is actually "Happy Birthday." I think you're going to like this next story, Dad. It's definitely from the dads point of view. It's about being a father. Ian Brown recorded this for us at a show that we did in front of a live audience.
哦，绝对不是。这首歌其实是“生日快乐”。爸爸，我觉得你会喜欢接下来的这个故事。它绝对是从父亲的角度出发的。是关于做父亲的。伊恩·布朗在我们要面对现场观众表演的一场节目中录下了这个故事。
No one arrives fashionably late for a seven-year-old's birthday party. That offends rule one of parental life-- never waste free babysitting.
没有人会在七岁小孩的生日派对上赶时髦地迟到。那违背了育儿生活的第一条规则——永远不要浪费免费的临时保姆。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But all seven guests at my daughter Haley's seventh birthday party were dropped off by their parents mysteriously seven minutes early. That sort of behavior is just plain rude. It was like being swarmed by a gang from Planet Tiny. They dropped their coats in the hall and immediately scattered to the farthest corners of the house like some new, instantly contagious form of biological weapon.
但是我女儿海莉七岁生日派对上的七位客人都被他们的父母神秘地早到了七分钟。那种行为简直无礼。就像被一群来自“微型星球”的团伙包围了一样。他们把外套丢在门厅，立刻像某种新型且瞬间传染的生物武器一样，散布到房子的各个角落。
And I staggered upstairs with a small mountain of coats in my arms, which is not a chore I saw myself performing back when I was young and longing to be grown up. Even when I was 11, I wanted to be married because married people, I knew, had sex every night of their lives.
我怀里抱着一大堆外套踉踉跄跄地上了楼，这可不是我年轻、渴望长大时预想到的那种杂务。甚至在11岁时，我就想结婚，因为我知道已婚人士每晚都有性生活。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But that's another story. I was lugging coats. Back downstairs, Trish, the mother of Katie, Haley's best friend, two best friends ago, Trish shot me a knowing look. Magician, right? How can you tell, I said. Fiber optic wands by the forks.
但这又是另一个故事了。我搬着外套。回到楼下，海莉两任前最好的朋友凯蒂的妈妈翠西向我投来一个了然的眼神。魔术师，对吧？我说，你怎么看出来的？叉子旁边有光纤魔杖。
And that was the first hint that my wife and I might have gone slightly over the top birthday wise. That we might have stepped over the strict moral boundary that separates caring, thoughtful parents who believe in personal attention and quality time from cheese balls like us who try to buy their way into their children's hearts.
那是第一个暗示，说明我和妻子在生日筹备上可能有点过火了。我们可能越过了那道严格的道德界限——将关心、体贴、相信个人关注和高质量时光的父母，与我们这种试图用金钱收买孩子心的奶酪脑袋分开了。
It's easy to commit that social gaffe these days. My wife and I both work. The harder we work, the guiltier we feel. The more we want Haley's birthday parties to be-- well, visible from outer space would be gratifying. We'd been planning Haley's seventh birthday, or to be slightly more accurate, my wife, Johanna, had been planning it, and I'd been doing nothing--
这些天很容易犯这种社交失礼。我和妻子都在工作。我们工作越努力，负罪感就越深。我们越希望海莉的生日派对——嗯，能被外太空看见就令人满足了。我们一直在筹划海莉的七岁生日，或者更准确地说，我的妻子乔安娜一直在筹划，而我什么都没做——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--for weeks. What there was, was a cake iced by professionals in the shape of a magician's top hat, which cost 30 bucks, eight loot bags filled with thoughtful, age appropriate, peanut-free party favors at $15 a bag, and of course, the magician himself at $150 for two hours. He called himself the Amazing Robert.
——持续了几周。现场有专业人士装饰的魔术师高礼帽形状的蛋糕，花了30美元，八个装满体贴、适合年龄、无花生的派对礼物袋，每个15美元，当然，还有那个魔术师，两小时150美元。他自称“神奇的罗伯特”。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I don't think he meant that ironically.
我不觉得他是自嘲。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Now, I like to do something special on Haley's birthday. Still, don't you think, I said to my wife as she frantically tried to find a magician who wasn't booked three months in advance, don't you think we might be overamping? But honey, if we don't go slightly crazy, Johanna said quite logically, some other parent will. Then what's Haley going to think? And anyway, do you have a better idea?
现在，我喜欢在海莉的生日做点特别的事情。不过，我不禁问妻子，当她疯狂地试图寻找一位没有被提前三个月预约的魔术师时，你不觉得我们可能太用力了吗？但亲爱的，如果我们不稍微疯狂一点，乔安娜很逻辑地说，别的父母也会。那样海莉会怎么想？再说，你有更好的主意吗？
And I did not have a better idea. My sole contribution to the magician party had been to suggest that we include a whoopee cushion in every loot bag, or at least, it was my idea to blow them up [BLOWING] and put them in the loot bags pre-inflated. In the old days, when Haley was small, we kept her birthday simple. I learned that lesson when I lived in Los Angeles near Beverly Hills.
我确实没有更好的主意。我对魔术师派对的唯一贡献就是建议在每个礼包里放一个放屁垫，或者至少，我的想法是把它们吹起来[吹气声]，预先充好气放进礼包。过去，海莉小时候，我们让她的生日保持简单。我是在洛杉矶贝弗利山附近住的时候学到那个教训的。
In Beverly Hills, parents like their children's birthday parties to have a theme and a fairly significant theme at that-- manifest destiny, say, or a NASA moon shot. In LA, I never went to a birthday party that featured anything less than pony rides. And one mother actually gave out Gucci T-shirts in the loot bags. And it was hard to compete with that.
在贝弗利山，家长们喜欢让孩子的生日派对有一个主题，而且是一个相当重大的主题——比如，“天命论”，或者NASA登月计划。在洛杉矶，我参加过的生日派对都有小马骑乘。一位母亲甚至在礼包里送了Gucci T恤。这很难竞争。
In an act of defiance, a friend of ours, a struggling writer, staged her daughter's birthday in a park, of all places. And the kids had a good enough time. They ran around and swung on swings and played tag and generally reveled in the whole two hours when they weren't under the watchful eye of a nanny or armed response security.
为了反抗，我们的一位朋友，一个挣扎中的作家，把她女儿的生日办在公园里，是在那个地方。孩子们玩得很开心。他们四处奔跑，荡秋千，玩捉人游戏，在没有保姆或武装安全人员的监视下，整整两个小时沉浸在快乐中。
The grab bags contained what grab bags are supposed to contain-- candy, rather than Rolex watches. And afterwards, the Beverly Hills parents flocked, they literally flocked around our friend. Fabulous idea, they said. Nature-- who would have thought? Can I steal a theme?
礼包里装的是礼包该装的东西——糖果，而不是劳力士手表。事后，贝弗利山的父母们成群结队地围着我们的朋友。精彩的主意，他们说。大自然——谁会想到？我可以借用这个主题吗？
But our friend Katharine is the queen of the less is more, easy on mummy birthday party. She says children want strong experiences, not new ones, which is why last weekend, for her daughter, Mary's seventh birthday, Katharine invited six girls over to string gummy bears onto extra long bamboo satay skewers. That was the theme of the party--
但我们的朋友凯瑟琳是“少即是多”、“妈妈轻松办生日派对”的女王。她说孩子们想要的是强烈的体验，而不是新的体验。所以上周末，为了庆祝她女儿玛丽的七岁生日，凯瑟琳邀请了六个女孩来把小熊软糖串到超长的竹制沙爹签上。那就是派对的主题——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--skewering candies on a stick. There was some risk of eye injury and the entire gimmick seemed to have Freudian undertones. The little girls kept saying, I'm going to stick this skewer up gummy's tiny butt--
——把糖果穿在棍子上。这有眼睛受伤的风险，而且整个噱头似乎带有弗洛伊德式的潜台词。小女孩们一直说，我要把这根签子插进小熊的屁股里——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--and giggling hysterically. But all in all, it was a winner. Only one girl barfed. The entire party cost 15 bucks-- Canadian.
——然后疯狂地咯咯笑。但总的来说，这是一个胜利。只有一个女孩吐了。整个派对花了15美元——加元。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
It is true that Katharine had a pinata. Pinatas are excellent because they entail hitting an object violently with a stick. But those were the old pre-bacchanalian birthdays. By the time Haley turned five, the year of our most corrupt and therefore most successful birthday, we'd gone as low as a parent can go. We'd hired human Barbie.
确实，凯瑟琳有个皮纳塔。皮纳塔很棒，因为它们需要用棍子猛烈地敲击一个物体。但那些是过去酒神狂欢前的生日了。等到海莉五岁时，那是我们最腐败、也最成功的一次生日，我们已经降到了父母能降到的最低点。我们雇佣了真人芭比。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For $300, human Barbie dressed up in full-sized versions of Barbie doll outfits and came to your house. Human Barbie arrived in a Dodge Grand Caravan with human Mitch, her assistant--
花了300美元，真人芭比穿上全尺寸的芭比娃娃装束来到你家。真人芭比坐着道奇大篷车，带着她的助手真人米奇——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--two giant mobile racks of party dresses for the girls, a tea set in a case, and two chests of makeup. She dressed the kids, discussed the possibility of multiple careers, and fed them cake. All our friends were completely horrified.
——两架巨大的便携式派对裙子架、一套箱装茶具和两盒化妆品。她给孩子们打扮，讨论多重职业的可能性，并喂她们蛋糕。我们所有的朋友都彻底惊呆了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I might as well have said, oh, this year, Haley's having a crack party.
我还不如说，哦，今年，海莉要办一个快克派对。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We're having a cake made of crack, too. My Canadian friends put this crassness down to the fact that Johanna, my wife, is an American. But successful? Well, it was as if the Dalai Lama had made a stop at our house. The girls were hypnotized with awe. They spent most of the afternoon standing in a circle, brushing human Barbie's hair.
我们还有一个用快克做成的蛋糕。我的加拿大朋友把这种粗俗归咎于乔安娜，我的妻子是个美国人。但成功吗？嗯，就像达赖喇嘛在我们家停了一站一样。女孩们被深深震撼。她们大部分时间站在圈子里，给真人芭比梳头。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I had the feeling that secretly, quite a few mums wouldn't have minded giving it a try themselves. As it turned out, I needn't have worried about the Amazing Robert, the magician, either. He was a handsome guy with sideburns and a wry, if somewhat resigned, manner.
我有一种感觉，私下里，不少妈妈自己也想试试。事实证明，我完全不必担心神奇的罗伯特，那位魔术师。他是个帅小伙，留着鬓角，带有一种自嘲、甚至有点宿命的风格。
He knew what he was doing, though. He started cracking jokes with the kids right away. You must be Haley, he said to one of the boys as he walked through the door. No, Peter said. I'm a boy, and clapped his hands. Hey, the magician said. No clapping. So all the kids clapped. I said, no clapping.
但他知道自己在干什么。他一进门就开始跟孩子们开玩笑。你一定是海莉吧，他走进门时对其中一个男孩说。不，彼得说。我是个男孩，然后拍手。嘿，魔术师说。别拍手。于是所有的孩子都拍手。我说，别拍手。
By the time he started pulling eggs out of their noses, you know they were goners. And I chose that moment to run upstairs. And I find I need a moment alone at regular intervals at these kiddie birthday bashes-- also at adult parties. In fact, I could use a moment alone right about now.
当他开始从他们鼻子里掏出鸡蛋时，你知道他们彻底被折服了。我选择了那个时刻溜上楼。我发现我在这些小孩的生日狂欢上定期需要独处的片刻——在成人派对上也一样。事实上，我现在就想要片刻的清静。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But when I opened the door to my bedroom, what do I find lying, lying on my bed, surrounded by entire mountain ranges of miniature winter coats? Two of my adult guests holding hands. Their spouses were downstairs. I must say, they played it cool. Headache, the woman said, rubbing her temples, not that I asked. Yeah, I said. These kids' parties can be brutal.
但当我打开卧室门时，我发现什么躺在床上，周围环绕着整座微型冬季外套的山脉？我的两位成年客人手牵着手。他们的配偶在楼下。我必须说，他们表现得很冷静。头痛，女人说，揉着太阳穴，并不是我问的。是的，我说。这些孩子的派对真是折磨人。
And I tell you, I left fast. I didn't want to ask. I certainly didn't want to know. And downstairs, the Amazing Robert was making cards disappear and reappear, but Trish, Katie's mom, she kept staring at the magician. I thought she disapproved of his tricks, but then she gave a little shriek. I know, she said. I knew I knew that magician! He has just come through a terrible divorce from a birthday clown.
我告诉你，我走得很快。我不想问。我当然不想知道。在楼下，神奇的罗伯特在表演牌消失和再现，但凯蒂的妈妈翠西一直盯着魔术师。我以为她不赞成他的戏法，但随后她尖叫了一声。我知道了，她说。我认识那个魔术师！他刚跟一个生日小丑完成了一场可怕的离婚。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which pretty much says it all, doesn't it? It's terrible, getting older. The disappointments and the letdowns, but no child believes that. They want to get older. And if you're seven, you can't wait to be nine. I mean, nine, that is going to be the greatest because they think life just gets better and better and better the older you get.
这基本上说明了一切，不是吗？变老真是太糟糕了。失望和挫折，但没有任何孩子相信这一点。他们想变老。如果你七岁，你迫不及待想变九岁。我的意思是，九岁，那将是最棒的，因为他们认为越长大生活就越好，越好，越好。
We grown-ups, we know better, or we think we do, or at least we need to think we do. But I didn't have much time for such maudlin thoughts and, frankly, convoluted ones because a new sound was wafting in from the living room, a sound it is, frankly, impossible to be maudlin about.
我们成年人，我们知道真相，或者我们认为我们知道，或者至少我们需要认为我们知道。但我没有太多时间思考这种伤感，坦率地说，甚至是令人费解的想法，因为客厅里飘来一种新的声音，一种坦率地说不可能感到伤感的声音。
[FARTING SOUNDS]
[放屁声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
They'd found the loot bags. Crass? Sure. Cheesy? Absolutely. Grown-up? Not at all. That's what I liked about it. Thank you.
他们发现了那些礼包。粗俗吗？确实。低级趣味吗？绝对。成熟吗？一点也不。这就是我喜欢它的原因。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Ian Brown is a roving writer for the Globe and Mail in Toronto, also the author of The Boy in the Moon, A Father's Journey to Understand His Extraordinary Son, and 60, My Year of Aging Semi-Gracefully. Hey, Dad, it's time for us to give stations a chance to do their local ID breaks and local promos, so I think you have a piece of copy there in front of you.
伊恩·布朗是多伦多《环球邮报》的游记记者，也是《月亮男孩：父亲理解他非凡儿子的旅程》和《60岁，我优雅衰老的一年》的作者。嘿，爸爸，是时候让电台做本地ID插播和本地推广了，我想你面前有一份稿子。
I do. Coming up, one father leaves, another one returns, in a minute, when our program continues.
我有。接下来，一位父亲离开，另一位回归，一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, our special Father's Day edition. And co co-hosting with me for this day is my own father, Barry Glass, now a certified public accountant in Baltimore, but once upon a time, back in his early 20s, a DJ.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，我们的父亲节特辑。今天和我共同主持的是我的父亲，巴里·格拉斯，现在是巴尔的摩的一名注册会计师，但很久很久以前，在他20岁出头的时候，是个DJ。
Ira, you also said you wanted a song dealing with fathers.
艾拉，你也说想要一首关于父亲的歌。
That's right. Did you bring in a song dealing with fathers?
没错。你带来了关于父亲的歌吗？
I did.
我带了。
What have we got?
是什么歌？
It's by somebody that you may have never heard of because you're too young-- maybe you have-- Eddie Fisher.
是某个人唱的，你可能从来没听说过，因为你太年轻了——也许你听过——艾迪·费舍尔。
The only way that I know who Eddie Fisher is-- wasn't he one of Elizabeth Taylor's husbands?
我唯一知道艾迪·费舍尔的方式是——他不是伊丽莎白·泰勒的丈夫之一吗？
That's right. That's right.
没错。没错。
He was the one before the guy who she did Cleopatra with. Is that right?
他是她拍《埃及艳后》之前的那位，对吧？
That's right.
没错。
How very sad for Eddie Fisher. This is all [LAUGHS] I know. Here I am, a person in my mid-30s, an educated person. That is all I would know about him.
艾迪·费舍尔真是太可怜了。这就是我[笑声]所知道的。在这里，我是一个30多岁、受过教育的人。这就是关于他我所知道的一切。
Richard Burton was married to Elizabeth Taylor after Eddie Fisher.
理查德·伯顿是伊丽莎白·泰勒在艾迪·费舍尔之后嫁的人。
["OH MY PAPA" BY EDDIE FISHER]
[艾迪·费舍尔演唱的“Oh My Papa”]
The name of a song is "Oh My Papa."
这首歌的名字是“哦，我的爸爸”。
(SINGING) Oh my papa, to me, was so wonderful. Oh my papa, to me, he was so good. No one could be--
（歌唱）哦，我的爸爸，对我来说，他是那么好。哦，我的爸爸，对我来说，他是那么好。没有人能——
Dad, it's like Jewish mariachi music.
爸爸，这听起来像犹太马里亚奇音乐。
Is that on point for Father's Day?
这符合父亲节的主题吗？
You couldn't get more on point. Actually, one of our producers--
没法更符合了。其实，我们的一个制作人——
You go around singing that about your father?
你会到处唱这首歌来谈论你的父亲吗？
I will now, Dad. I promise. At least for the day, at least for Father's Day. Do you want me to do it now?
我现在会的，爸爸。我保证。至少今天，至少在父亲节。你要我唱吗？
No, that's OK.
不，不用了。
No, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it. No, no, I'm going to do it.
不，我要唱。我要唱。不，不，我要唱。
I've heard you sing, Ira.
我听过你唱歌，艾拉。
You can't stop me. (SINGING) When he would take me on his knee and with a smile, he changed my tears to laughter. Oh my papa. Dad, this is going out to you. To me, he was so wonderful. Oh--
你阻止不了我。（歌唱）当他把我抱在膝盖上，带着微笑，他把我的泪水变成了笑声。哦，我的爸爸。爸爸，这首歌是唱给你的。对我来说，他是那么好。哦——
Ira, my heart is breaking.
艾拉，我的心都要碎了。
(SINGING) I miss him so today.
（歌唱）我今天真的很想念他。
We're now at Act 3, "The Moment Dad Left."
我们现在进入第三幕，“父亲离开的那一刻”。
In this act, we have a story from Jay Allison. Jay Allison is this radio producer that all the people who kind of work behind the scenes in Public Radio, we all know him, and he does these really unusual little stories. He lives in Woods Hole, Massachusetts, Cape Cod. And one of his neighbors is a guy named Dan Robb, and Dan Robb is a writer and a teacher and a carpenter.
在这一幕中，我们有一个来自杰伊·艾利森的故事。杰伊·艾利森是那种在公共广播后台工作的人都知道的广播制作人，他做这些非常不寻常的小故事。他住在马萨诸塞州伍兹霍尔的科德角。他的邻居之一叫丹·罗布，丹·罗布是一位作家、教师兼木匠。
And Jay and Dan had an idea for a little radio experiment. Dan's father left his family when Dan was a little kid, just, I think, three or four years old. And Dan remembered that night vividly, or he thought he did. But he never discussed this with his parents. So Dad, Jay encouraged Dan to talk to his parents about this on tape. And I'm going to play you the story they put together, OK?
杰伊和丹有一个小小的广播实验主意。丹的父亲在丹还是个孩子的时候就离开了家庭，我想才三四岁。丹清楚地记得那个夜晚，或者他以为他记得。但他从未与父母讨论过这件事。所以爸爸，杰伊鼓励丹在录音里跟父母谈谈这件事。我要给你放这段他们录制的故事，好吗？
Yeah, I'd like to hear it.
好的，我想听听。
I remember clearly the morning they told me they were separating. I was three, and they leaned over my bed, which was narrow, and told me this, something like, "Don't think this changes anything, but Dad's moving out." And what I remember is telling them that it was not OK.
我清楚地记得他们告诉我他们要分居的那天早晨。我当时三岁，他们俯身在我的窄床上，告诉我这件事，大意是：“不要觉得这改变了什么，但爸爸要搬出去了。”我记得我告诉他们这并不好。
Then, later that day, I remember watching my father's back as he walked down the stairs outside the house. They were cement and had a black wrought iron banister running up both sides. And he was walking down the steps away from me. He had a brown tweed jacket on and brown leather shoes, and he was carrying two brown suitcases. He put them in his Jeep, back when they still said "Willis" on the side, and he drove away.
后来那天，我记得看着父亲的背影，他走下屋外面的楼梯。楼梯是水泥做的，两边有黑色的锻铁扶手。他正走下台阶离开我。他穿着一件棕色粗花呢夹克和棕色皮鞋，提着两个棕色手提箱。他把它们放进吉普车里，当时车侧面还写着“Willis”，然后开车离开了。
The steps were cement steps, pretty steep, about three flights, three little flights, three steps, and then a landing and three steps down. And there was something crooked about them. one of the steps sort of went off at an angle. And there was an iron railing along the way, not very pretty.
台阶是水泥台阶，相当陡，大约有三段，三小段，三级台阶，然后一个平台，再下三级台阶。而且它们有些弯曲。其中一级台阶歪了角度。沿途有一根铁栏杆，不是很漂亮。
Now, if I looked out the window and watched Dad packing his car and then driving away, at that time, what kind of car would it have been?
现在，如果我看着窗外看着爸爸打包车子然后开车离开，当时那会是什么车？
Well, he had bought a little sports car because his car was in the garage, in the shop, and he didn't want to wait till it was ready, which would have been two or three days later. And he bought a little car so that he could leave right away. And he told me he was leaving on a trip across the country because that's what he had to do in order to clear his mind and get his feet on the ground again. So he packed up, and he got in this little sports car and took off.
嗯，他买了一辆小型跑车，因为他的车在修车厂，他不想等到车修好，那可能需要两三天。他买了一辆小车以便能立刻离开。他告诉我他要去全国旅行，因为那是他必须做的，为了清醒头脑，重新站稳脚跟。所以他打包好，坐进这辆小跑车出发了。
What kind of car was it?
那是什么车？
It was a little Triumph, a little two-door. It was a neat little car, which I sort of got special for the trip. And I just wanted to-- I just drove out West. I mean, I just wanted to get away from Pittsburgh and just sort of clear my head out, I thought. And I remember telling Allison that when I got back, I thought I would want to move out.
那是一辆小凯旋，两门车。那是一辆漂亮的小车，我为了那次旅行特意弄到的。我只是想——我只是开车去了西部。我的意思是，我只是想远离匹兹堡，想清醒一下头脑。我记得告诉过艾利森，等我回来时，我就想搬出去了。
I had a lot of different feelings. I was angry that he'd done it. I was angry that he hadn't ever taken Dan and me-- you and me on a trip.
我有很多不同的感觉。我生气他这么做了。我生气他从来没带丹和我——你和我去旅行过。
And he was walking down the steps away from me, and he was carrying two brown suitcases. He put them in his Jeep back when they still said "Willis" on the side, and he drove away. A little while before he left that day, he knelt down in front of me and tightened my belt for me. I have a picture of that. His hands are big, bigger than mine will ever be, farmer's hands or a ballplayer's hands. And he is cinching the belt gently tighter and saying something to me.
他走下台阶离开我，提着两个棕色手提箱。他把它们放进吉普车里，当时车侧面还写着“Willis”，然后开车离开了。他走前不久，跪在我面前，帮我系紧皮带。我有一张那样的照片。他的手很大，比我的永远都要大，是农夫的手或者是球手的手。他轻轻地把带子收紧，对我说了些什么。
I mean, I feel bad about all of the sort of gaps when I wasn't there. And all of that time, I mean, once it's gone, it's gone. You can never get it back. And relationships, in many ways, are built of memories. And the more memories you have, the deeper the relationship. And if you're missing several years of memories, that's hard.
我的意思是，我对那些我不在身边的空窗期感到难过。所有那些时间，一旦过去，就再也回不来了。关系在很多方面是由记忆构成的。拥有的记忆越多，关系就越深。如果你缺失了多年的记忆，那就很困难。
Well, there's a snapshot of his doing your belt up for you when you were probably three or four. You were four when he left, weren't you?
嗯，有一张你大概三四岁时他帮你系带子的快照。他离开时你四岁，对吧？
And I don't remember exactly what the season was. It had to have been fall, I think, because I remember taking a lot of pictures of you in the subsequent weeks when we get together, go to the parks and stuff. And it was all autumn shots.
我不记得具体是什么季节了。一定是在秋天，我想，因为我记得在接下来的几周里拍了很多照片，当我们聚在一起去公园玩的时候。全都是秋天的照片。
And he is cinching the belt gently tighter and saying something to me. I can't make out the words in the picture, which is black and white, and shows me standing there at three years old in front of the big window that let the monochrome Pittsburgh light into the living room.
他轻轻收紧带子，对我说了些什么。在照片里我听不清那些话，那是一张黑白照片，显示我当时三岁，站在巨大的窗户前，让匹兹堡单色的光射进起居室。
The light is stark, as if all of the coal burned to smelt the steel in that city had burned the color out of the air. And it reflects off his hair, which is smooth with Vitalis, and shows his strong jaw and the depth of his dark eyes. There was no abuse in that household, no harsh words that I could hear. Just nothing. No father anymore and my mother sobbing over the dishes in the sink.
光线非常刺眼，就好像城市里冶炼钢材燃烧的煤炭烧尽了空气中的颜色。光线映在他抹了发油的头发上，展示了他坚毅的下颚和深邃的黑眼睛。那个家里没有虐待，我听不到任何尖酸刻薄的话。只是没有了。再也没有父亲了，我母亲在洗碗池边啜泣。
What do you think you would have done after he had packed up his car and left? What would have been your reaction that I might have observed?
你觉得在他打包好车离开后，你会做什么？我可能观察到的你的反应会是什么？
Oh, you probably saw me sad and mournful, but then turning back to the house and trying to look cheerful. But I also felt abandoned, and I felt that it was the end of a marriage, the end of my hopes for marriage, the end of my hopes for a family for you and me. And he left us.
哦，你可能看到我伤心哀痛，但随后又转回屋里，试图装作开朗。但我感到被抛弃，我觉得那是一段婚姻的结束，是我对婚姻希望的结束，是我为你我期望的家庭生活的结束。他离开了我们。
But I also felt, as he drove out of sight, well, thank goodness. What a sense of relief. I am free of all that abuse and misunderstanding and bad feeling that have been going on for so long. I thought, well, at least I can be me now and not try to be something that somebody else was making me be.
但当他开出视线时，我也感到，好吧，谢天谢地。有一种如释重负的感觉。我终于从那些长期存在的虐待、误解和坏情绪中解脱了。我想，好吧，至少我现在可以做我自己了，不用试图成为别人强加于我的样子。
The split-up was my doing and coming out sort of a combination of my own immaturity, restlessness, dissatisfaction, inflated hopes, and expectations. And I guess I just felt that I had never had any kind of freedom. Of course, I mean, I never really found freedom afterwards. You sort of think, well, you're going to change your life, and then lo and behold, your life turns out to be about the same.
分手是我的错，源于我自己的不成熟、不安分、不满、膨胀的希望和期望。我猜我只是觉得我从来没有得到过任何自由。当然，我的意思是，之后我也没真正找到自由。你会认为，好吧，你要改变生活，结果发现你的生活差不多还是原样。
I was three when they leaned over my bed, which was narrow, and told me this. Don't think this changes anything, but Dad's moving out. And what I remember is telling them that it was not OK.
我三岁时，他们俯身在我的窄床上，告诉我这件事。不要觉得这改变了什么，但爸爸要搬出去了。我记得我告诉他们这并不好。
I didn't want him to tell you first, and he didn't want me to tell you first. So we did it together. And I remember I knew it was a terrible blow for you.
我不希望他先告诉你，也不希望我先告诉你。所以我们一起说了。我记得我知道这对你是个沉重的打击。
I don't remember telling you with her.
我不记得和她一起告诉你这件事了。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
You were in bed, I remember. I mean, at least I have this picture in my mind and in that little room at the Maple Heights. And I came in, and I said, started to say something like, Dan, I'm going to be leaving, and whatever I was going to say. And you somehow knew what was coming.
记得你在床上，我还记得。我的意思是，至少我在脑海里和那间枫叶高地的房间里有这个画面。我进来，我说，开始说些像“丹，我要走了”之类的话，不管我要说什么。你不知怎么预感到了。
It was not OK.
这并不好。
And you said, I don't want to hear it, and sort of like put a pillow over your head, and didn't want to listen. And it was a wrenching moment. It really was.
你说，我不想听，然后就像用枕头蒙住头，不想听。那是一个揪心的时刻。真的是。
And I mean, I've thought since then that actually, when I walked out of your bedroom that night, that that was really a major turning point in my life. And I don't know, to this day, whether it was for good or ill.
而且，我的意思是，从那以后我一直在想，其实，那天晚上我走出你卧室时，那确实是我生命中的一个重大转折点。直到今天，我不知道这到底是福还是祸。
When my father left my bedroom, it was a turning point for me, too. It was the moment I moved outside the myth of the American family, left it and became a part of something else, something with no affirming mythology to look forward to and my restless memories of that day to look back on.
父亲离开我卧室的那一刻，对我来说也是一个转折点。那一刻我走出了美国家庭的神话，离开了它，成为其他事物的一部分，一种没有肯定神话可以期待的事物，只剩下那一天不安的记忆让我回首。
I became a part of divorce, which is like the death of the family. And I turned down a path less well-marked, less well-lit. But I, unlike my father, no longer wonder if it was for good or for ill. It just is.
我成了离婚的一部分，那就像家庭的死亡。我走上了一条标记较少、灯光较暗的路，但我，不像我父亲，不再怀疑这是福还是祸。它只是发生了。
OK, well, I think that's about it, huh? This will be on the radio right before Father's Day. So I'd like to wish you Happy Father's Day.
好了，我觉得大概就是这些了，嗯？这会在父亲节前在广播里播出。所以我想祝你父亲节快乐。
Oh, OK. Thank you.
哦，好的。谢谢。
You're welcome. And maybe we can make something good out of this.
不客气。也许我们可以从中创造出一些好的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
So thank you so much.
所以非常感谢。
OK.
好的。
All right, I love you.
好的，我爱你。
Love you, man.
我也爱你，哥们。
OK, talk to you soon.
好的，回头聊。
Yeah, bye.
好的，再见。
Bye.
再见。
Jay Allison and Dan Robb made that back in the '90s when we first broadcast today's show. Hey, Dad.
杰伊·艾利森和丹·罗布是在90年代我们第一次播出今天的节目时制作的那段录音。嘿，爸爸。
Yes, Ira.
是的，艾拉。
Do the next act open, please.
做一下下一幕的开始，拜托。
Act 4, "Reconciling With Dad."
第四幕，“与父亲和解”。
This whole show is like reconciling with Dad, though you and I, we don't need to reconcile, but.
整个节目就像是与父亲和解，虽然你和我，我们不需要和解，但是。
No, we don't.
不，我们不需要。
We don't. But Dad, this next story is about a father and son. The father was this pretty well-known man here in Chicago named James D. O'Reilly. He was an actor here and a director from the 1960s through the 1980s. And among people who went to theater, just, he's one of these people who everybody knew.
不需要。但爸爸，接下来的故事是关于一对父子。父亲是芝加哥一位相当知名的人，叫詹姆斯·D·奥莱利。他是60年代到80年代这里的演员和导演。在看过戏剧的人中，他就是那种大家都认识的人。
He was artistic director of the Body Politic Theater and the Court Theater. And he wasn't the most reliable dad. And his son is a guy named Beau O'Reilly, who's a playwright and a local musician and stages a lot of theater here in town. And Beau has this story about his father, including a moment in their lives when they did reconcile, in a way.
他是“政治身体剧院”和“法院剧院”的艺术总监。他不是最可靠的父亲。他的儿子是一个叫博·奥莱利的家伙，他是位剧作家和本地音乐家，在城里导演了很多戏剧。博有一个关于他父亲的故事，包括他们一生中以某种方式和解的时刻。
When I was a little kid, five or six, my father would do these big variety shows, these musical revues for college theater groups. And I would often appear with him, playing the bad kid in town or the clown screaming the lines of "This Old Man" from the top of a stepladder. And at the show's end, we would rush first to the bar, where my father knew all the girls' names, and then to the train station to catch the last train home.
当我还是个五六岁的小孩时，我父亲会组织这些大型综艺表演，这些是为大学戏剧团体准备的音乐汇演。我经常和他一起登台，扮演镇上的坏孩子或者在大梯子顶端尖叫着唱“这位老先生”的丑角。表演结束时，我们会先冲向酒吧，那里我父亲认识所有女孩的名字，然后去火车站赶回家的末班车。
And I would get very tense then and hot in my stomach, like I was going to burn up and pass out. So we would often miss the last train home and have to spend the long hours till morning waiting in the train station, my father falling quickly asleep, his huge head thrown back in the train waiting room seat. It seemed to hang at an impossible odd angle from the rest of his body like the dot at the bottom of a question mark that knows it has to be there, but hangs odd and unattached.
那时我会感到非常紧张，肚子发烫，感觉就像要烧起来昏过去一样。所以我们经常错过回家的末班车，必须在火车站等待直到清晨的漫长时光，我父亲很快就睡着了，他巨大的头向后仰在候车室的座位上。它看起来悬挂在一个不可能的奇特角度，脱离了他身体的其他部分，就像一个问号底下的圆点，知道自己必须在那里，但悬挂得又奇怪又不搭调。
And the scene, my father drunk and snoring, a big question mark of a presence, would be repeated numbers of times over the next 25 years. My father passed out at the family table on Christmas morning, my father nodding off behind the wheel, my father snoring through the still Latin mass, my father's head thrown back in the last row during my high school production of The Glass Menagerie.
这一幕，我父亲醉醺醺地打着呼噜，作为一个巨大的问号存在，在接下来的25年里重复了无数次。我父亲在圣诞节早晨在全家面前昏睡过去，我父亲在驾驶座后面点头打盹，我父亲在安静的拉丁弥撒中打呼噜，我父亲在我高中演出《玻璃动物园》时在最后一排仰着头打呼噜。
But when he was awake, he was not totally present either. He was this silent, brooding man home once a week for our family dinner. And I would sit up all night in that train station, listening to the muted rumblings of the next morning's diesel engines and the fluttering of pigeons in the ceiling above, my father's snoring made rusty and noisy by too much cigarettes and beer.
但当他清醒时，他也不完全在场。他是个沉默、忧郁的人，每周只回一次家吃家庭晚餐。而我会通宵坐在候车室里，听着第二天早晨柴油机低沉的轰鸣声，听着上面天花板鸽子的扑腾声，听着父亲因为吸太多烟和喝太多酒而变得沙哑、吵闹的呼噜声。
When I was 29, something changed between me and my father. I was 29, very drunk most days. And I came home to Chicago to work for my father, I guess. I had rarely seen him in my alcoholic adulthood, his alcoholic adulthood having taken him away from the family circle years ago. And when my father, he got me this job as a house manager and sometimes understudy at his theater on Lincoln Avenue. And he was warm and kind about it, I guess.
当我29岁时，我和父亲之间发生了变化。我29岁，大部分时间醉醺醺的。我回到芝加哥为我父亲工作，我想。在我的酗酒成年期我很少见到他，他的酗酒成年期多年前就把他从家庭圈子里带走了。当父亲给我安排了在林肯大道剧院做剧场经理和偶尔做替演的工作时。他表现得很热情、体贴。
This kindness was unusual. It was hard for me to recognize it. I didn't know whether it was kindness really or not. Maybe he just recognized something in my swaying walk and my overly bright, loud way of speaking, a kindred alcoholic spirit. We would from then on do our drinking together late nights at the pub next door to the theater, a pub where we could sit for hours, get a burger and a beer, a pub where my father ran a tab, and I was always on the tab.
这种体贴很不寻常。我很难识别那是不是真的体贴。也许他只是认出了我摇晃的步伐和过度明亮、大声的说话方式中，一种同病相怜的酗酒者的灵魂。从那时起，我们会在剧院隔壁的酒吧里一起喝到深夜，在那里我们可以坐上几个小时，吃汉堡喝啤酒，在那儿我父亲签单，而我也总是在那个账单上。
Now, the pub tables were family long, with my father always at the head and crowded with actors and confidants, all with one ear pointed at my father, hoping for a good joke from him, which usually came, or some word of praise, which came rarer, but when delivered, were always delivered with a flair and a passion.
酒吧的桌子很长，我父亲总是坐在头位，周围挤满了演员和心腹，所有人都侧着耳朵听我父亲说话，期待他能讲个好笑话，那通常都会讲，或者得到他的几句夸奖，那很稀罕，但一旦说出来，总是充满了热情和激情。
These tables would start full, full of people and huge pints of black Guinness and brown beer, but by 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning, they would be empty, except for my father and I. Me talking loud and feverish now, lovers and women and broken hearts and politics and plays and broken hearts and lost lovers and lost women and broken hearts. And me doing most of the talking, my father nodding and grimacing, looking appropriately sad.
这些桌子开始总是坐满人，满是巨大的吉尼斯黑啤酒和棕色啤酒，但到了凌晨1点或2点，除了我和父亲就空无一人了。我说话的声音很大，带着狂热，谈论着情人、女人、破碎的心、政治、剧本、破碎的心、丢失的情人、丢失的女人和破碎的心。我在说大部分的话，父亲点着头，做着鬼脸，看起来非常悲伤。
But his eyes looking away always, scanning the bodies of the young women who moved about in the pub's waning hours. Sometimes these women stopped by the table to speak to my father, him finding sly ways to kiss and touch and pinch them, locking their eyes with his as if his eyes were gift enough to allow him his inappropriate touching.
但他的眼睛总是看向别处，扫视着在酒吧深夜时光中穿梭的年轻女性。有时这些女性会停下桌子跟我父亲说话，他会用狡猾的方式亲吻、触摸和掐她们，用他的眼睛锁住她们，仿佛他的目光就足以允许他进行不适当的触摸。
The pub would close with us still in it, the tables having adopted the chairs and now holding them piggyback. And my father would sign his tab with a flourish, and we would part company. Me often watching him walk slowly up Lincoln Avenue, a large man with a lordly old-fashioned head, always aware that he was like something out of Shakespeare or O'Neill. He might be swaying, but swaying with a charm and a dignity.
酒吧关门时我们还在里面，桌子已经把椅子背在背上放好了。父亲会挥洒自如地签单，我们便道别。我经常看着他缓缓走上林肯大道，一个有着高贵、老派头颅的大块头，总是意识到他就像莎士比亚或奥尼尔戏剧里的人物。他可能摇晃着，但那摇晃带着魅力和尊严。
The further my father got up the street, the more real he felt to me. There. There. That was the father I knew, half a courtyard away under the hot lights doing Shakespeare's Lear or Brecht's Galileo. And I would stand on Lincoln Avenue crying, the crying of a 29-year-old drunken baby whose father is moving away, always moving away. And that baby knows he's better off having Dad go.
父亲离得越远，我越觉得他真实。在那里，在那里。那是我认识的父亲，离我半个庭院，在炽热的灯光下表演莎士比亚的《李尔王》或布莱希特的《伽利略》。而我会站在林肯大道上哭泣，那是一个29岁的醉酒婴儿的哭泣，父亲在离去，总是离去。而那个婴儿知道他还是让父亲走的好。
I learned a lot watching my father's theater that year, wonderful productions of Playboy of the Western World and Ronald Harwood's The Dresser, Brian Friel's Translations. My father's performances were always in the center of the plays. And I was the house manager. I was skittish in a baggy suit and non-matching vintage ties, greeting the audience at the door, selling them coffee, but mostly watching the performances night after night.
那一年我看着我父亲的剧院学到了很多，精彩的制作，像《西方世界的花花公子》、罗纳德·哈伍德的《化妆师》、布莱恩·弗里尔的《翻译》。我父亲的表演总是在戏剧的中心。而我是剧场经理。我穿着宽大的西装和不配套的复古领带显得有些局促，在门口迎接观众，卖咖啡，但更多的是夜复一夜地看着表演。
My understudy assignment was not something any of us ever expected to use, but one week, here it comes. An actor could not appear, and I was to play my father's tortured, crippled son. It was an Irish play about an Irish father and his Irish sons, and I was an Irish son, never mind that I had an Irish brogue like Ringo Starr's Liverpool.
我的替演任务不是我们中任何一个人预想会用到的，但有一周，机会来了。一名演员无法演出，我要扮演我父亲受尽折磨、身患残疾的儿子。这是一部关于爱尔兰父亲和爱尔兰儿子的爱尔兰戏剧，我是一个爱尔兰儿子，哪怕我说话的爱尔兰口音像林戈·斯塔尔的利物浦味儿。
And I'd never appeared on a professional stage. There would be one rehearsal. My father not even on stage, but seated in the audience, chain smoking, hung over, barking orders, orders that moved my body hot and frightened, clumsily around the stage, me mumbling the lines and standing in all the wrong places.
我从来没在职业舞台上表演过。只有一次排练。父亲甚至不在台上，而是坐在观众席里，链式吸烟，宿醉，吼叫着命令，那些命令让我的身体热得发慌、笨拙地在舞台上走动，我嘟囔着台词，站在所有错误的位置。
And the night of the performance, I was pacing and shaking in the hall outside of the green room where my father and the rest of the cast were making up and preparing to perform. I could hear them talking, but they couldn't see me at all. They didn't know I was there.
演出当晚，我在化妆间外面的走廊里踱步、颤抖，我父亲和其他演员正在化妆准备演出。我能听到他们说话，但他们看不见我。他们不知道我在那儿。
And one of the actors said, with a good actor's projection and precise actor's diction, "Get ready for amateur night." "What did you say?" My father said it quietly, but with force. "Get ready for amateur night." "Well, he'll be fine. You worry about yourself. Prick."
其中一个演员用专业演员的投射力精确的字典说：“准备好迎接业余之夜吧。”“你说什么？”父亲轻声说，但很有力。“准备好迎接业余之夜。”“好吧，他会没事的。管好你自己。混蛋。”
Now, this is the only time I ever heard my father defend me. And I now realize the significance of that. But at the time, I was very angry. And it was the anger that burned the fear out of me like a fog on a new hot summer Sunday. And I was fine when I hit the stage. I was understudy good enough.
这是我唯一一次听到父亲为我辩护。我意识到那意义重大。但当时我非常愤怒。正是那愤怒像炎炎夏日周日的雾气一样烧掉了我的恐惧。当我走上舞台时我感觉很好。我的替演水平足够了。
And when I played to my father, his eyes a deep well into the heart of Brian Friel's Translations, I actually enjoyed myself. There were moments of real emotion between us. And on the stage, my father was really there. Like I could reach out and touch him, and he would really be there.
当我对着父亲表演时，他的眼睛像是布莱恩·弗里尔《翻译》心中的一口深井，我真的乐在其中。我们之间有真实的情感时刻。在舞台上，父亲真的在场。就像我可以伸出手触碰他，他就会真的在那里。
And when the lights came down, I stumbled offstage, tripping and falling in the dark. My father was waiting, his big, noble actor head shaggy with sweat, his arms open to receive me. We, hugging, missed the curtain call-- probable first for my father. He was not one to miss a curtain call.
当灯光熄灭时，我跌跌撞撞地走下舞台，在黑暗中磕磕绊绊。父亲在等我，他那高大、高贵的演员头颅蓬乱着汗水，双臂张开接住我。我们拥抱在一起，错过了谢幕——这对我父亲来说大概是头一回。他可不是那种会错过谢幕的人。
A few months later, my father fired me during his production of The Dresser by Ronald Harwood. My father playing Sir, a bullying, tyrannical, Shakespearean actor Sir. My father was not one to shrink from typecasting.
几个月后，父亲在罗纳德·哈伍德的《化妆师》演出期间解雇了我。父亲扮演“爵士”，一个霸道、专横、莎士比亚式的演员。父亲不是那种会回避本色出演的人。
And one of my assignments was to meet him in the lobby, holding a towel, which he would use to wipe the makeup and sweat from his face before returning to the stage for the curtain call. I wasn't there with the towel. I had wandered off to the pub for a pint before the show ended.
我的一项任务是在大堂里接他，拿着毛巾，他在回到舞台谢幕前用它擦掉脸上的妆容和汗水。但我没拿着毛巾在那儿。我溜去酒吧在表演结束前喝了一品脱。
The truth be told, there were probably many nights when I wasn't there. I was off crying into the phone, running off the long distance phone bill for the theater or selling dope out of the theater concession stand to my friends. I was 29 and drunk most of the time.
说实话，可能有很多个夜晚我都不在那儿。我要么是在电话里对着哭，给剧院增加高额的长途电话账单，要么是在剧院小卖部向朋友卖毒品。我29岁，大部分时间都喝得烂醉。
And my father, he recognized me for what I was. I was becoming very much like him in my 29th year, and perhaps he was embarrassed and uncomfortable having to see himself in me every day. And he was fired soon after from his theater on Lincoln Avenue. And we continued to meet in the pub night after night for many months.
而我父亲，他认出了我是什么样的人。我在29岁时变得非常像他，也许他看到每天在自己身上重现的影子感到尴尬和不适。他后来很快从他在林肯大道的剧院被解雇了。我们在酒吧里日复一日地见了几个月。
Bill O'Reilly is a Chicago playwright, and he's also the co-host of the Rhinoceros Theater Festival, which today's show is a rerun. It is now in its 34th year. He'll be performing on July 1 in a tribute to Bob Dylan.
博·奥莱利是芝加哥剧作家，也是“犀牛戏剧节”的联合创办人，今天的节目就是那里的重播。戏剧节现在已经进入第34个年头。他将在7月1日表演一场鲍勃·迪伦致敬演出。
["PAPA, CAN YOU HEAR ME?" BY BARBRA STREISAND]
[芭芭拉·史翠珊演唱的“爸爸，你能听到我吗？”]
So Dad, you're sitting there in a studio in Baltimore. I'm here in Chicago. Do you have our credits?
那么爸爸，你坐在巴尔的摩的录音室里。我在这里芝加哥。你有演职员名单吗？
I do have your credits.
我有。
All right.
好的。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and Ira Glass with Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wiber. Our contributing editors are Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and the fabulous Margy Rochlin.
我们今天的节目是由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和艾拉·格拉斯制作的，还有彼得·克劳尼、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威伯。我们的特约编辑是保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和了不起的玛吉·罗奇林。
Special thanks today to Bob Carlson at KCRW in Santa Monica for recording Sandra Tsing Loh, her father, and the band, Boy Hits Car, and to Dave Johnson at WJHU, the fabulous Dave Johnson for getting my dad on tape and out here.
今天特别感谢圣莫尼卡KCRW的鲍勃·卡尔森录制了桑德拉·清·罗、她的父亲和乐队Boy Hits Car，也感谢WJHU了不起的戴夫·约翰逊把录音带搞定并送出来。
Music help today from Chicago's John Connors. The story about Dan Robb's father leaving comes from Jay Allison's series, Life Stories, which is funded by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and the National Endowment for the Arts.
今天来自芝加哥的约翰·康纳斯提供了音乐帮助。关于丹·罗布父亲离开的故事来自杰伊·艾利森的系列节目《生活故事》，该节目由公共广播公司和国家艺术基金会资助。
That was so smooth. Additional help in today's rerun from Matt Tierney, Stowe Nelson, and Alaa Mostafa. Also worth mentioning Boy Hits Car, the band that we heard from in Act 1, has a new album coming out later this year, 2023. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
真是顺畅。今天的重播还有马特·蒂尔尼、斯托·纳尔逊和阿拉·穆斯塔法提供的额外帮助。还值得一提的是，我们在第一幕里听到的Boy Hits Car乐队今年晚些时候2023年有新专辑发行。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
And I'm Barry Glass.
我是巴里·格拉斯。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life. Till then, don't drive like my father.
下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。在此之前，别像我父亲那样开车。
Don't drive like my son.
别像我儿子那样开车。